you have all these ideas and at this
point you should be wondering which idea
should I choose well to answer that
question you have a lot to think about
here are some of the considerations you
should keep in mind first is your idea
at painkiller or vitamin painkillers
address an obvious and functional need
for users while vitamins address users
emotional needs and are really nice to
have now both types but especially
painkillers can lead to successful
companies for vitamin type ideas you'll
need to figure out how to get your users
to be sticky so that way they continue
to come back and use your product over
time the second thing you should look
for is how easy it is to monetize the
idea now you don't need to monetize an
idea on day one but understanding how to
make money out of the service or product
is essential to building an enduring
business next is the idea simple can you
explain your idea in just a couple
sentences for example bag bars still
calm is like Netflix but instead of
running movies you can rent buy or sell
designer items law enforcement and
judges might say the simplest
explanation is usually to the right or
truthful one and this should also be
true of your product users should be
able to describe the product and its
benefits to other potential users easily
and here's where we get to the heart of
the matter is your idea personally
relevant for example you might be a
diabetic and want to develop affordable
and convenient blood sugar monitors for
other diabetics now don't underestimate
this one this is of great importance as
it relates to how likely are to
persevere in the face of challenge
uncertainty are worse looming failure
you'll be more likely to see an idea
come to life if you care about the idea
in the first place now another
consideration for your idea is whether
or not you can follow through on it
think about your ability to organize a
small team or a large team to execute on
that idea can you get from A to B next
you should wonder if you have a large
enough size of the market you want a
really big slice of the pie the market
just refers to your number of potential
customers you should be able to
calculate a lower estimate as well as an
upper estimate for your market size if
you're unfamiliar with market sizing
refer to the instructor notes there's a
resource link there and finally does
your idea have a legitimate secret sauce
does your idea leverage technology are
patents in a unique way or do you have
talent and capital that no one else
would ever have for Google the secret
sauce was the PageRank algorithm the
secret sauce has grown over the years to
include many features that bring
millions of page results in fractions of
a second now that you have some
considerations for what makes a great
product idea I'd like you to evaluate
the idea for the super duper shopping
app you can find a survey that's linked
in the instructor notes once you've
taken the survey you can check this box
to continue when you're done